les républicains j'ai fait partie de
ceux là j'étais l'auteur d'une loi en
octobre de l'année dernière qui a été
votée en décembre de l'année dernière
qui généralise et le bracelet anti
rapproche mais c'est le bracelet anti
rapprochement c'est pas le l'amande
parce que vous avez siffler quelques
dans la rue c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus important c'est de choses
qui permet de protéger des femmes qui
sont en danger de mort et ça compte
beaucoup plus que les déclarations à
deux sous de marlène schiappa la loi a
été votée en décembre de l'année
dernière
elle devait être appliquée cette
généralisation du bracelet anti
rapprochement en janvier c'est ce que la
garde des sceaux nous avait expliqué en
janvier on nous a dit finalement ce sera
en juillet et en juillet nous allons
finalement ce sera en septembre et nous
sommes le 22 ou 23 septembre aujourd'hui
il n'y a toujours pas le déploiement des
bracelets anti-rapprochement dans notre
pays vous voyez bien que le baratin ça
ne suffit pas à protéger des femmes est
d'ailleurs le chiffre des féminicides de
l'année dernière a montré que notre pays
était un échec c'est ce qu'on vous
avance comme argument pour dire que ce
n'a pas encore été déployés
on nous avance des arguties on nous
explique qu'il faut lancer les appels
d'offres qui vous faire des
consultations qui a les problèmes
bureaucratiques sauf que la vérité s'il
n'y a pas de volonté politique vous avez
entamé la semaine dernière un tour de
france de l'écologie avec les
républicains
ça consiste en quoi l'écologie vu par
les républicains ça consiste d'abord à
rappeler que la droite
historiquement a beaucoup fait pour la
protection de l'environnement georges
pompidou qui crée le premier ministère
de l'environnement jacques chirac il
fameux discours de johannesbourg nicolas
sarkozy et jean louis borloo le grenelle
de l'environnement
et c'est la droite républicaine qui a
fait le plus sur les questions
d'environnement et la déclaration
peut-être non non pas seulement des
déclarations tout ce que j'évoque là ce
sont des actes majeurs qui ont été
portés ce que je sais en revanche c'est
que je fais partie de cette génération
de trentenaires qui ne supporte pas que
ce sujet essentiel sur la protection de
l'environnement qui nous préoccupe tous
soit aujourd'hui kidnappé par des
extrémistes de tous bords et comme je ne
veux pas demain que ce sujet les
écologistes entre les mains soit entre
les mains d'écologistes qui orientaient
de plus de déconstruire la vision notre
société que de s'occuper de
l'environnement
eh bien je dis que la droite ne doit pas
abandonner ce sujet l'environnement
c'est un sujet qui nous intéresse tout
ce qui me passionne et je pense que la
droite républicaine doit aussi porter un
espoir sur ce sujet